so here it is this is the van at about
98% completion so everything's basically
done and I'm gonna do a bigger van tour
of everything but for now I'm just
shooting a little intro video to let you
guys know that there is going to be a
new channel and we'll talk a little bit
about this we'll come inside and I will
show you the van it is messy and I'm
showing you it messy on purpose because
you know life isn't always a so perfect
got some lights here you can see that
I've actually spent some time sleeping
in here we've got the monitor set up so
that I can do work keyboard got some
trash from some socks that I bought I
things a little bit messy we got some
speakers here there the cabinets there
will be a fuller van tour but just not
for the time being at the vacuum out
because I was doing some work
skateboard rack here no skateboarding
it's where you go driving got a Gatorade
up top here we have a shower this thing
pulls out and cool and then showers not
up right now it's a it's a little wand
or whatever so there's a little bit more
work that has to be done the next step
is going to be let me let me show you
guys actually so the wheels are a little
small the wheels are stock from when I
bought the van and we're gonna do a lift
and then put beefier tires on this so
that this thing can go up on the road
and survive better now you can't really
see from here but there's solar panel
solar panels and air conditioning and
there's a Wi-Fi and mobile cellular
antenna up on top again I'm gonna do a
much better van tour he's like a GoPro
get some better shots explain all the
electronics and everything but you know
I think what we can do here is pull this
chair out of the way and just talk to
you about what's going on and one of the
reasons why I wanted to get started on
this ASAP is that well you know what let
me set this camera up so we can actually
do a proper conversation so I don't know
what the sound is gonna be like here
admittedly I'm in the van and I've set
up this kind of janky setup but I wanted
to talk to you a bit about the goals for
this channel and this is gonna be like a
light intro and it's all
these videos like the old game videos I
have in here as well as this will
probably get replaced at some point but
I need to stress one important thing
about why I decided to do all this right
now for one come this weekend the
mosquito come this weekend this the
final modifications to the van are gonna
be underway it's gonna be the suspension
spine suspension lift and the bigger
tires right now like a badge it's got
the stock tires and we need an upgrade
if it's gonna go on the road for
extended periods of time and hopefully
it will handle it but I think so I've
got a bunch of electronics and water
systems it's gonna be pretty rad video
games everything I need to do for for on
the road production so two things are
gonna happen once around the road now as
well this weekend is the big event so
I'm gonna be handing it's off to the
mechanic going and doing the event and
then a couple days later the men will be
done I'll be heading back up to
Connecticut for just like a last round
and then I still need to find somebody
as like a second-in-command who wants to
drive in film but I have a few people in
mind who may end up doing it we'll see
what happens and then I'm going to Texas
that's that's the first trip so like I
said there's gonna be two things that we
produce out of this I'm gonna be doing
on the ground field reporting so I this
this field reporting stuff will be
specifically for sub verse mostly I mean
there's no guarantee subversive will
publish it my publish here but the goal
is if I produce a straightforward on the
ground news piece it's gonna be like
documentary interviews it's called like
Verity a documentary it's kind of the
stuff that I was doing advice where
someone follows me around and all
pointed things and be like oh hey look
there's the border and there's a person
let's go talk to them things like that
um the van allows me to produce my
regular schedule so I'll still be doing
all of the same content on my main
channel my second channel and then in
between that for this channel it's going
to be kind of just travel fun adventure
stuff so you know we'll see if we can
build up to that point it's gonna be
admittedly it's gonna be a lot of hard
work there's one really important thing
as to why I want to you know get all
this going for one the Vans about to be
done and this was the plan since May
when I made that video and it took a lot
longer than I thought
I said hey I'm gonna be doing a lot more
travel and stuff but I figured instead
of you know what my idea was back then
sorry there's a mosquito my idea back
then was to make my main channel more of
just like the travel on the ground stuff
and I figured it probably didn't make
sense because I built up an audience on
that channel specifically for you know
news and commentary so I just reduced
the workload for it
switching from an edited version to a
more like live shot like I do for all my
videos now and I'm gonna put the travel
stuff on here and there's one really
really important reason outside of the
fact that you know it's about to be
finished today I made a video talking
about the New York Times mainstream
breaking news the New York Times plowed
a story claiming Trump supporters are
you know targeting them and they're
they're offended or whatever it's fine
and they were they were slammed by the
left and the right about this like
saying you guys are not above you know
the regular people if you make
embarrassing tweets you'll get in
trouble I highlighted one of the
criticisms and it was offensive
so YouTube nuked the video the the view
count was like eighty thousand views in
an hour it shot up to 160 K and then
also I got the notice that it was
reviewed and they said highlighting that
story that shows the New York Times
staff are are bigoted I gotta be careful
it's ridiculous resulted in the the
whole video getting struck like not a
copyright strike anything but you can
see the analytics but like this and then
goes go straight down it was getting
something like 40,000 views in the past
hour and it dropped down to like eight
so that says to me one very very simple
thing as I've mentioned before and as we
all know moving into 2020 we know things
are going to get strict YouTube just
took out a bunch of all right channels
people who didn't break the rules but as
YouTube said was really you know we're
really close to doing it the problem is
that means YouTube has rules you can
follow all of them and they will say
yeah well you didn't follow him the way
we wanted you to follow him and they'll
try and claim that they're all about
free and open platforms they're not and
this is the big the big risk so this
channel is gonna be fun adventure travel
sub person's gonna be news Tim Casas
commentary on bigger stories you know
the main big breaking stories and Tim
cash news YouTube accomplished Tim cast
news is like individual stories so
that's kind of how the breakdowns gonna
happen so if you watch this which I
really really want you to this is also
like a you know look I'm a contingencies
for
contingencies sub verses straight news
no opinion on the ground reporting and
it is the work that I've done on my main
channel and second channel that allows
it to exist more importantly it is all
the the support and an investment from
people who helped make the channel grow
and get to the point where said now we
got a substantial investment for those
that don't know we raised 1 million
dollars and 22 hours that means there is
a staff working there there currently
going to be doing some on-the-ground
reporting some major places we already
have some excellent on-the-ground
reporting from Chicago and Portland
which is up so that's hopefully safe but
this is what's scary I made a video like
milquetoast fed center temple talking
about a mainstream New York Times story
explaining the criticism from the left
and the right and YouTube knocked it
down saying no here's the problem man
does CNN get D ranked I don't think so
the analytics show that CNN gets propped
up so all of my videos on my main
channel especially in the past several
months have been very basic mainstream
top political stories say for the the
media critic critiques that I've done
because that's you know I'm very
passionate about it but there have been
stories about you know Elizabeth Warren
Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump Trump
Trump over and over again because that's
the big mosquitos killing me that's the
big breaking news well today it's the
paper of record the New York Times being
criticized and think so here's gotta
happen I think about what happens when
you know come 2020 it's October and
YouTube says okay these youtubers are
causing us too much problem to look up
they're causing too many problems and
they're gonna help people we don't like
they're gonna strike us all down they
are and they're already starting to do
it so this channel will always be travel
but hey at least in the worst case
scenario I won't be homeless there's
never gonna be a circumstance where I'm
gonna go work for another company like
that it's not gonna happen at the very
least I can go work on the sub verse
more full-time I'm not it's it's
editorially independent I provide you
know a little bit of oversight for the
most part but that's just you know like
ethical standards and the main the main
issue is subversive on its own away from
me because I'm an I'm a political actor
although I'm a centrist and all that
stuff you know I'm in this so subversive
to be on
but I'm really worried that YouTube is
going to definitely hack my channels to
bits I I was sitting there watching you
know my video and I thought I gotta be
honest I don't swear I don't use slurs I
don't repeat them but I do show what
they said and YouTube doesn't
differentiate between text and speech
and I didn't think about that so now you
know I added a blur hopefully blurring
the slur from the New York Times
reporters will well does mosquito man
it's terrible hopefully adding that blur
will help I don't know but all I know is
this video was doing really really well
and everybody was like man this is
really great good job Tim great critique
and then YouTube said no you are not
allowed to show the New York Times
saying this so here's the problem
I show the sources so you know I'm
telling the truth
so you know it's verified I guess I can
show the source and blur the word I
guess that's right what I have to do I
don't say the words as it is but I'm
also concerned doesn't matter because my
opinions are not mainstream for the most
part that they kind of are but they're
not left you know they mean they're not
establishment so I think it's only a
matter of time before they strike my
channel down now admittedly my second
channels doing great but that's this is
this is the point this is why I'm
setting this up now so that you can come
to this channel and subscribe and with
the next week or so I will start
producing vlogs you'll see behind the
scenes you'll see on the ground you'll
see in the studio you'll meet people and
that's what it will always be and it'll
be fun in the worst case scenario when
YouTube chops my channels to bits and
throws them in the gutter there will be
two channels that are left sub verse and
this one and this one will be travel and
adventure with some new Z type elements
mixed into it there may be some things
kind of like change my mind think you
know where I sit down with talk with
people around the country and there will
be new stuff produced for sub verse but
I you know let it never be said that I
don't plan ahead so hopefully this
worked what's my time stamp pad I can't
believe I've been talking this long I'll
wrap it up here eventually I'll get rid
of this video and the other two but
there you go that's the plan and we're
getting really really close to pulling
the trigger winter is coming
haha funny but I will likely be on the
road probably in the south and I'll be
on the road for most of the time
covering various stories so even the
you know I'm gonna be producing my same
six segments one for the main channel
five a second channel and then after
that I'm gonna have someone with me
filming the vlog and us going on
adventures and filming stuff so we'll
see what happens but I guess that's uh
that's what I'll leave it there for now
thanks for hanging out check out this
new channel subscribe if you haven't
already I am gonna be pushing this
channel hard hard hard so stick around
and I will see you all tomorrow at 10
a.m. as per usual